Hey.
Conan O'Brien here.
If, like me, and I hope you're like me,
you are staying inside, you are hunkered down,
avoiding contact with other people and being safe,
well, you're probably bored right now.
A lot of us are.
Let's face it: we're looking for something to do.
Guess what's very popular at the moment?
That's right.
I think some of you just said it.
Jigsaw puzzles.
I prefer the old 1,000-piece puzzle myself,
but I want to be careful.
There's 1,000 pieces in here.
Each one could possibly be infected.
That's why I'm gonna take this very simple precaution,
and I suggest you do as well.
I take all the puzzle pieces and I'm going to boil them.
Boil each piece.
What you want to do is really stir it around.
I suggest you sing the Happy Birthday song
for every puzzle piece.
That's the Happy Birthday song 1,000 times.
♪ Happy birthday to you ♪
♪ Happy birthday, dear puzzle piece ♪
That's one.
♪ Happy birthday to you ♪
See? You can add different sort of accents.
All right.
That was 1,000 times.
It's been three and a half days.
I'm soaked in urine.
Pour it out.
Get your pieces.
Ahh!
Thwomp.
There we go.
Let it cool.
And you can start trying to prep the pieces where they...
that's really hot.
Not sure what that used to be.
You really sometimes...
Yeah, that's a problem.
Uh, well, makes it more challenging.
You gotta put these pieces down first
and match 'em to the piece that washed away.
So in a way, it's now become a 10,000-piece jigsaw puzzle.
Well, hope this helped.
I'm sure it did.
I've got work to do.
Ah, dang it!